I like went on a date once and it was  when I was 13 and it was at the movies  and then what movie um I have no idea  and it was the day before Valentine's  Day and then he he kissed me and then he  said that was not as magical as I  thought it was going to be some night  his baby his uh he was super rich and is  his Butler literally his mother his  Butler was there the entire time but in  a different movie theater and he took  him and he left and I was stuck there no  one told me that they were like gonna  leave and then and then and it was the  day before Valentine's Day and then a  baby came up to me and then the baby  looked at me and I was like I was like  oh my god a baby and it's smiling at me  in it and I smiled and it started  screaming and crying and I was what a  day one day I had oh my god it's  unbelievable and also you get is hella  ugly now you know what right good